Speaker 1: All right, everybody buckle in. These
next two segments are pretty, pretty full on nuts.
Over the weekend, Donald Trump spoke at another
one of these right wing events of no consequence.
This particular event was in Austin, Texas. Now,
we had a correspondent on the ground talking to
Trumpists. And we're going to get to those videos
in a moment. But first, what did Donald Trump say?
This is maybe the most callous moment of Donald
Trump's political career. Now, I know he made fun
of the disabled reporter and yelled out, Where's
my African American? He's had all these cringe
moments. But this is wacky Trump going on stage
and saying, I think they had a tragic event in
Buffalo referring to the mass shooter who targeted
black people, killing ten, injuring three,
and somehow transitions into bragging that nobody
died in Afghanistan while he was president.
It's a bizarre and disturbing
political moment. Take a look at this.
Speaker 5: We didn't lose one American
soldier. Think of it. Not one.
As opposed to last night, which you saw in
Milwaukee and you saw, I guess, a total of 20 and
different. And just as I'm coming off the stage, I
think they had a tragic event in Buffalo, just as
I'm coming on the stage, tragic event in Buffalo
with numerous people being killed in 18 months
in Afghanistan. We lost nobody I spoke with.
Speaker 1: What what is the connection between
those two things? It's outrageous that in the same
sentence as domestic gun violence, he's talking
about Afghanistan. This shooting in Buffalo didn't
happen thanks to Biden. I mean, is that what he's
suggesting, that, listen, when I was president,
nobody died in Afghanistan, but there was a mass
shooting in Milwaukee and a mass shooting in
Buffalo. And I'm no longer president. But Biden
is like, is that the implication? And in fact,
this is particularly egregious. It's particularly
disgusting because the right wing rhetoric cited
in the alleged manifesto of the Buffalo shooter
is exactly the type of stuff that coalesced around
Trump and that was fomented by right wing media
when Donald Trump became president of the United
States. It's an outrageous comparison to make.
Trump also at one point said something really
weird about Elon Musk saying Musk has problems and
maybe Trump's social media platform is better. And
he again doesn't say it correctly. You guys know
how Trump glitches all the time and he recently
got the name of his own platform. Incorrect Truth.
Speaker 5: Central.
Speaker 1: Truth Central. Yeah,
he again botched it. It's very weird.
See if you can understand this.
Speaker 5: Who? It's hot and it's actually
much, much better than Twitter. It blows
Twitter away. Everybody loves it, especially the
engagement. I mean, it's amazing. Elon Musk So
I don't believe he's going to buy Twitter
because you have so many fake accounts, the bots,
all of the different things. I think it's
going to be very interesting and he's got
some problems because he bought a lot of stock
that he shouldn't have bought. He got a lot of
problems with Twitter, but the Twitter has a lot
of problems. So go to Charles Schulz social. I
think you're going to find Troll Central.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So I guess he's making
the point that truth essentially is better than
Twitter and maybe even better than truth social.
And then lastly, Trump says he's writing
a book called The Crime of the Century
about how, I guess the election was stolen from
him. Kind of getting sad at this point when you.
Speaker 5: Think about it. They go after other
people. They don't want to go after criminals who
kill people on the streets. They go after other
they go after they like going after Republicans.
That's what they really like. This is the
greatest this is the crime of the century.
I'm actually writing a book about called The
Crime of the Century. I don't think you'll
enjoy it. You'll be very depressed when you.
Speaker 1: Well, I just don't believe Trump's
writing anything. Trump doesn't read and Trump
doesn't write, so none of it is making sense to
me. So a completely depraved event. Trump doesn't
know up from down, day from night. Left is right.
Unclear what's going on, but he continues to
be completely un empathetic in every way to
everything going on in the world. And next, let's
go to our interviews with some of his supporters.